yeah and so you had so many important
ideas in this book uh one is that the
mechanical or implementation is thought
of as being kind of subordinate uh or
lesser than the policy making apparatus
and you think about the folks in DC what
is it it's a think tank it's like hey
like we should be doing this policy we
should be doing that policy and then uh
actually delivering that policy to the
American people is sort of like oh no
that's someone else's problem it's like
not not a big deal or you know it it's
for the lessers to figure out delivery
and then but you said look for most
Americans the delivery is a policy or
the website is the policy it is that's I
mean has any of us read the tax code
lately no but we pay our taxes and that
is how we experience the tax code it's
this you know it's also true of people
getting social benefits like snap
um you don't go read the eligibility
rules you don't go you know read this
now okay and that's how you find out and
I think that's true of so many things
but that's the delivery apparatus the
people who do delivery is not valued
it's considered sort of yeah I mean I
hate to say it but second class work in
government and so and it's not just that
second class work and sort of there's
not attention paid to it we actually
pour enormous resources into it
I think what it is is that we try to
pretend that there's no judgment
required in it it's just something that
people can take orders to do they're
going to do exactly what somebody above
them has said to do and they should not
um express any creativity or judgment or
create priorities that's why I hear from
teams all the time anyone who knows like
if you design even like a basic web page
you have to make a dozen judgments
probably 100 judgments not even a dozen
and what are those judgments supposed to
be made on they're supposed to be made
by what is going to work for the person
who's going to use the website but we
try to take the person who's going to
use the website and out of it what we
tell people who do delivery and
government to look at is a whole big set
of requirements that have come down from
inside the bureaucracy that's why we
talk about meeting government needs
instead of meeting user needs now I know
we're going to need to meet government
needs but it's about what comes first
the user needs need to come first and
then we fit in and you know meeting some
of these compliance requirements all
these government needs but that's the
part of the shift that needs to
happen if we're going to have these
things work yeah so I think you should
give rise to a movement Jennifer I'm
going to give you a terrible acronym for
it right now it's Maguire which is make
government work again
you could take or leave that it's
totally fine
um but I I here here's my my big
question for you so I I'm a huge
believer in uh what you've laid out in
this book I think there's a desperate
need to recode America and make it so
that we're actually modern
um you talk about how look
investing in 21st century State capacity
is not something that uh there is any
political incentive around meanwhile I
think that this is the definition of
where we need to go as quickly as
possible because the problems are
getting worse in Harry our institutional
trust is getting lower and lower and so
the only way to turn it around is to be
like look guys we will actually deliver
for you we will be you know accountable
transparent to you really genuinely by
the way not only did I I run for
president I also even said down the
stretch I was like look
I think there should be a new secretary
of Technology uh and I think that you
should just make account names and I
hinted not so suddenly that I was like
and if this were to exist you know like
I'd be game for the job though I dare
say
um you'd be a better fit for it than me
but I was willing to to actually say
like look I would do this thing in part
because I was concerned about Ai and
thought that uh someone would need to
get out there and uh and actually try
and interface with the the AI
companies in a way that was uh more
Nimble and
um up to date as opposed to sort of wait
for it to turn through agencies anyway
um you're still needed Andrew well
thanks got it for you too
um so but but so I I now am a huge
believer in Maguire or the rise of the
Mechanicals or whatever we're gonna call
this thing
um but uh and you end the book with
something of an Earnest call being like
look like part of this stuff is actually
getting in there uh applying your
energies there are a lot of Heroes
Within These bureaucracies and
organizations like we have to kind of
free them to be able to to do the right
thing
um but it did get my mind racing too
okay let's say that I was actually in
that seat like how could we clear the
path for people to be able to do the
right thing
you mean to go into government
or or like if it's because one of the
things that I totally agree with you on
is that we have this Byzantine crazy
layer of code legal code that we just
keep adding things to uh and then and
you say look even if I were to transpose
this into the cloud it's still a mess
like I just took like a like a bale of
um that would have made me think of is
like extension cords you find in a
drawer it's like you open it you're like
hey I want to take this to the cloud
it's like well it still looks like a
freaking extension cord ball exactly
yeah I mean I think we kind of need to
start moving the Overton windows so to
speak
um
you know you think it take unemployment
insurance for example like there was
some talk during the pandemic of maybe
we need to federalize this program
which is one you know one sort of major
shock to the system that could change
things but you know I what I didn't hear
was we need to dramatically simplify
this I mean really how hard is it right
like we're gonna create some eligibility
rules and then some benefit rules and
there's got to be some rules for
adjudication but it's not 25 years of
learning that you know it's not it
shouldn't be so complicated it takes 25
years to learn
um I think there are places where we
need to be able to say
we have to zero base this program like
let's go throw it all out and design a
program that would work for 2024 and
2025. the thing that frustrates me so
much right now and your book like
illustrates us over and over again is
like is the dumbness of the
conversations we have which is you know
we need we need more money you know we
need we need less money it's like no no
we just actually need that works
like you know and if I spent 10 of what
I'm spending now and get 85 of value
like I would be pumped it was supposed
to be pumped the problem is right now
we're spending 100 and getting 10 of the
value and then we're like arguing and be
like you know why you know why you're
mad it's like we needed more money it's
like did you really need more money
well you probably didn't need more money
and the average American senses this
they're pissed off because they're like
you are not using my money effectively I
can sense that and then that gives rise
to like legitimate uh anger so so the
the thing that I want to say Maguire or
rise the Mechanicals is it's like the
actual true Middle Ground is like you
know you you don't necessarily want I
mean like I can say like in some domains
you probably do want smaller government
but in in some domains you probably want
government that just does its job better
like actually delivers and then on the
the liberal side it's like look guys
like you can point at the rule book uh
like all day long but if we can't get
stuff done for people what's the point
you know what I mean like like you're
using the the the code as an excuse not
to deliver and then if if someone does
try and deliver by the way and this is
the cage that we've cut the government
employees in because they're like oh I
can't do it because of rules right
they're stuck they have this terrible
accountability trap where they're
they're judged by following the rules uh
but when following the rules doesn't get
you the outcomes then they you know
everyone's mad about them about the
outcomes but we've got to remove that
accountability trap and we need uh sort
of philosophy of our government that's
about removing those barriers not just
about passing new legislation vision